هذه ساحه الحريه في وسط خركيف هذه ليست
اكبر ساحه في اوكرانيا فقط وانما هي اكبر
ساحات البلاد الاوروبيه قطبه من خلفي يوجد
مبنى الاداره الاقليميه التي تم قصهم من
قبل الطائرات الروسيه هذا المبنى بات
خاليا تماما بعد ان تم تدمير جزء كبير منه
في هذه الغاره ايضا هذه الساحه كانت ملئه
بالسيارات والمواطنين وهي الان شبه خاليه
تماما بعد ان اجبرت الحرب التي استمرت
لمده عام كامل المواطنين على البعد عن هذه
الاماكن التي قد تتعرض للقصر في اي وقت
كان ايضا من خلف يوجد اثنين من الجامعات
الاوكرانيه الكبيره هذه الجامعات لا يوجد
بها طلاب كما هو الحال ايضا في المدارس
الاوكرانيه التي بات التعليم فيها عن بعد
بعد ان اجبر الطلاب على ترك جامعاتهم
والتعلم عن طريق الواقع الافتراضي
نحن موجودون في ارضنا وهذه بلادنا ولا
نفكر في الخروج منها سنواصل للنهايه لطرد
هذا العدو الغاشم وسنعيد بناء بلادنا مره
اخرى رغم ما لحقها من دمار وخراب كان
الروس سببا فيه
هذا السوق الذي نقف فيه هو سوقا السوق
الشعبي الاكبر في اوكرانيا السوق الذي بني
على مساحه 300 الف متر مربع ويحوي اكثر من
ثمانيه عشر الف محل تجاري دمرت اجزاء
كبيره منه جراء القصف الروسي التجار
الموجودون هنا يتحدثون عن انهم كانوا
يعانون شحا ماليا قبل الحرب لكن بالطبع
معاتهم زادت جراء هذه الحرب التي استمرت
لعام كامل
المحل الخاص بي وباسره احترق بالكامل
وانفقنا كامل مدخراتنا لتوفير اخر نحن
نحاول ان نواصل العمل لرغم الصعوبات
والحرب المدمره المشاكل والصعوبات في
الماضي كان يمكن حلها
عن اي ارباح وتجاره تتحدث الان ليس لدينا
اي مصدر رزق بوتين قال انه اتى ليحررنا لا
نفهم من اي شيء انه يريد تحريرنا تقول
السلطات هنا ان جزءا كبيرا من هذا السوق
الشعبي الذي دمر جراء الحرب سيتم تحويله
الى مباني سكنيه وذلك لاعاله الاسر التي
دمرت بيوتها خلال عام الماضي لكن بالطبع
سياخذ هذا وقتا ليس بالقصير لقناه العربيه
والحدث احمد بجاتو مدينه خر كيف